for the June issue of Vanity Fair
Catherine O'Hara was photographed at
home with the help of drones going full
bloom with a variety of wigs now in the
new interview Catherine revealed that
she briefly dated her shits Creek
co-star Eugene Levy years ago thang
cooked I think we went out to breakfast
once I think we must have kissed but
nothing further because he was a
gentleman and I'm a good Catholic girl
she also admitted to having a bit of a
crush on Martin Short after watching him
in the 1972 Toronto production of
Godspell think quotes I took the program
home and I remember kissing his picture
because I thought he was so adorable
funny enough
Martin revealed in the same interview
that everyone has been in love with
Kathryn since she was 17
Martin also shared a funny story about
being in mid conversation with Tom Ford
and Angelica Houston at a dinner party
in LA when Kathryn walked in Scent quote
Angelica went completely still she said
oh my god oh my god I've got to meet her
I've got to meet her it was like Paul
McCartney walking in in 1965 now
Katherine revealed that her life changed
forever as a teenager when her older
brother started dating Gilda Radner and
brought her home for dinner my mom would
definitely break out the good plates she
remembers how the SNL alum treated her
like a younger sister saying quote she
had me sleep over one night and then in
the morning we sat there at her little
kitchen table with a pretty cloth we had
tea and pumpernickel bread with cream
cheese and cucumbers you come from the
suburbs something like that is so cool
and chic and exotic say hello to all my
new hashtag friends the little word I
assembled to consecrate my fans who are
also my friends okay friends doesn't
sound nice Catherine also opened up
about being nominated for an Emmy for
the first time for lead actress in a
comedy for shits Creek saying quote the
only thing I was bummed about was that I
didn't get to do my bit which I thought
was funny I swear it's not about not
getting the award it's oh I had such a
good bit I'm playing Moira Rose
Catherine
admits that she's a little different
than the glamorous Maitreya from the
show in person I'm just meet Oh awesome
a lovely and then I'll go on forever
telling long stories I'm nowhere near is
interesting as more as it is all but
impossible to explain why things happen
the way they do our lives are like
little baby crows carried upon a curious
wind dan levy who created the show with
his dad Eugene also spoke about the joy
of working with his TV mom you're
dealing with a caliber of actor who is
so seasoned and so willing to make
choices that are outside people's
comfort zones I think that's what Moira
Rose is a result of Kathryn having the
runway to go for it so what did you
think of Katherine's interview with
Vanity Fair and how about those pictures
I mean only she can make cutting lemons
look that cool let me know in the
comments below
[Music]